is Jay Powell running in what feels like
a never-ending race his goal of bringing
down inflation through aggressive
interest rate hikes is probably going to
take the Federal Reserve on a journey
that drags on and on at least that's the
read from a group of professional and
Retail investors pulled by Bloomberg
when asked to compare pal to a track and
field athlete most respondents said he's
competing in a marathon in part because
of the delay between the fed's action of
raising bar and costs and the reaction
in the economy of prices coming down
former treasury secretary Larry Summers
agrees he tweeted that history indicates
inflation doesn't tend to fade quickly
meanwhile almost a third of investors in
the Bloomberg survey compare pallets to
a pole vaulter in a sign of concern over
how high he'll go in raising interest
rates whatever Palace event endurance
will be a big theme as the Central Bank
needs to decide on its next step the FED
is waiting to see evidence that its
series of rate hikes since March 2022
will weaken demand to borrow money
reducing spending in order to slow down
price increases for now most investors
are true using not to make any big bets
in stocks or treasuries even as they see
the dollar trading higher in
anticipation that Jay Powell will be
running laps for a while
[Music]